[Music]
hi welcome to this busy Friday news
night Joe Biden once said and I quote
when a woman alleges sexual assault
presumes she is telling the truth
needless to say Biden has now done a
complete 180 will call out the ramp and
hypocrisy coming up and a new allegation
tonight as we come on the air this
Friday night also big news on the Durham
bar probe Jay Sekulow Flynn attorney
Sidney Powell they will join us they
will update us also tonight how is it
even possible the colossal fell epic
fail of New York City and state the
worst case of coronavirus and they did
everything wrong Rudy Giuliani will
weigh in our investigation tonight also
frustrated Americans all across the
country you're seeing it everywhere
there now beginning to revolt against
the lockdown wait'll we see the beaches
in Huntington this weekend in California
as 33 states now are in the process of
lifting restrictions and opening up and
at least one professional sports league
is only days away from returning to
action there is hope there will have
more in just moments but first we do
turn to our top story the hypocrisy the
deceit that is the modern extreme
Democratic radical socialist party now
for weeks Joe Biden well he has done his
best to ignore sexual assault
allegations levied against him by a
former staffer her name is Tara Reid too
graphic to repeat on television I guess
mica did it but we won't anyway already
today top Democrats across the country
have tried to give Biden cover with
glowing endorsements the mob the media
they asked them not one single question
about the Reid allegation the I
believers were nowhere to be found and
still are and after a mountain of
corroborating evidence emerged in this
case surrounding Reid's allegations the
media was guilted into covering the
story and Biden was finally forced to
answer serious questions about the
accusations and I do tip my hat I think
mica did a good job take a look to use
your words should we not start off with
the presumption that the essence of what
she's talking about is real she says you
sexually assaulted her look from the
very
and I've said believing women means
taking the woman's claims seriously when
she steps forward and and then vet it
look into it this this that that's true
in this case as well women have a right
to be heard and the pressured rigorously
investigate claims they make I'll always
uphold that principle but in the end in
every case the truth is what matters and
in this case the truth is the claims are
false all right as the left now are they
gonna treat Biden the way they treated
Kavanagh will they now demand an
investigation will they say I believe
her the way they did with the Cavanaugh
accusers even though they didn't have
half the corroboration they didn't have
any actually nor do they have a police
report nor did they have a haunting call
from the mother of any of the accusers
are they gonna comb through Biden's
decades-old yearbooks from high school
like they did Cavanaugh well they call
for him to step down as their party's
nominee
well they say I believe in this case
Tara Reid because that's what they
demanded in the Cavanaugh case without
any corroborating evidence whatsoever
the reed case she has it she has
witnesses she has the mother's phone
call she filed the report
but at the very least if Jo has nothing
to hide and he really wants to be
transparent like he says he does and get
to the truth like he says he wants he
can just release all the personnel files
on Tara Reid now they are reportedly
stored at the University of Delaware
with Biden Senate records now we know a
staff was in there already Biden doesn't
seem interested in that level of
transparency mmm speaks volumes take a
look why not approve a search of her
name in those records approve a search
of her name yes and the only thing that
might be related to Tara Reid in the
University of Delaware records there is
nothing they wouldn't they're not there
and if they if it's it you know I don't
understand what your point you're trying
to make nothing classified to the
President or anybody else I'm just
asking why not do a search for Tara
Reid's name in the University of
Delaware records look I mean who does
that search
Jos kind of seems like he's hiding
something or maybe just malfunctioning
as usual now we all know he's not
working with a fastball or even a curve
and I don't even think he has a soft
pitch at this point for that matter it's
actually really hard to watch but when
you remember as gray being calm pointed
out just a few months ago Biden was
promoting himself as a champion of all
victims rampant hypocrisy just like we
quit and Pro and quo and zero experience
hunter and you're not getting the
billion take a look the woman should be
given the benefit of the doubt and not
be not be you know abused again by the
system they say why do you think women
would give rape so many don't report it
they don't want to get raped again by
the system it's all about the abuse of
power number one number two women should
be believed know no matter what she's
wearing what she does who she is
unless you can affirmatively give
consent its rape unless you
affirmatively can say anybody engaged in
that behavior is committing a crime so
much has changed about how the public
understands the pressure on women and
I've learned a lot as well too there's a
class a hypocrite what happened Joe do
you no longer believe that women should
be given the benefit of the doubt now
that it's you on the other side of this
what about the well allegations the what
seven or eight of them against you
already and what about the endless
stream of creepy footage of you you know
getting way too close to just about
every female you can incite is this
really the champion for women that
Democratic Party is that the one they're
gonna nominate really as it turns out
most Democrats never really seem to care
about the issue because if they did they
would either take our position which is
the presumption of innocence take it
seriously look at the facts let people
decide that's the way you know it works
in this society but if you're a
Republican and conservative I believe
you're a Democrat silence they were just
using it as a political
weren't they in the Kavanaugh case and
against Trump the hypocrisy probably
never been worse than this take a look I
believe dr. Ford and to me judge
Cavanaugh has sown shown so clearly he
does not have the temperament or
credibility to serve on the Supreme
Court the courage she showed was
remarkable
dr. Ford's testimony was credible and
compelling I believe dr. Ford not only
do women like dr. Ford who bravely comes
forward need to be heard but they need
to be believed I believe dr. Ford I
believe the survivor here there's every
reason to believe her I believe
professor Ford I think she's credible
and Nancy Pelosi she's going to the mat
for Biden today we reached out to
well dozens of Democratic I believe her
lawmakers for a response not one person
had anything supportive to say about
Tara Reid not a single one most didn't
even get back to us the I believers in
the Democratic Party
conveniently evaporated into thin air
and utterly taking in breathtaking
hypocrisy just like with the quit in the
Pro and Nicole and pretty much
everything else if you're a Democrat
you're a liberal you get a pass you're a
conservative you get bludgeoned to death
this is especially true of Pelosi let's
look at her you may need a investigation
on justice Cavanaugh when a very similar
allegations
well let me just say I respect your
question and I don't need a lecture
earth speech we're here to show our
solidarity we're here to show our
respect for all women who have a case
have it respected the due process
investigate there's a lot of excitement
around the idea that women will be heard
and be will listen to the crimes
themselves yeah of the allegations that
have been made about offenses that have
a lifetime impact there is also due
process and the fact that Joe Biden is
Joe Biden dead of asking questions the
Republican leadership fears the truth
there was never any record of this there
was never any record really they're so
afraid of the truth and they're so
afraid a woman died dr. Christine Blasi
forged for the truth that she was still
till breathtaking groupthink hypocrisy
Democratic Party I don't care about
power we're consistent here we believe
in the presumption of innocence and that
you're innocent until proven guilty but
take it seriously sure everybody should
it's important and the worst part the
mob the media actively assisting them
every step of the way as late as
September 2019 wopo yes Eric pimples
paper The Washington Post they were
still plotting Cavanaugh's demise one
headline reading quote well calls for
justice Cavanaugh's impeachment are
mounting here's how it could work and
here's how the post covered the
accusations against Biden developments
in the air legations against Biden
amplify efforts to question his behavior
what does that even mean
meanwhile the New York toilet paper
times actually worked with the Biden
campaign to remove language about
Biden's misconduct from one of their
articles Wow
and in hand who worked together and now
one devout Democrat pretending to be a
news host just said that reads
allegations were part of a right-wing
smear campaign really when in doubt
blame the Conservatives take a look the
right isn't running an intellectually
honest operation to get to the
of whether Tara Reid was victimized the
right is running a smear campaign
against Joe Biden that's it okay Nicole
you say so you Steve Schmidt and Joe
will listen to all that and for the mob
and the media their partners in the
Democratic Party because that's
state-run conspiracy TV television right
let's be honest you know politics comes
first for them it's not about principles
not about victims rights not about well
due process a constitution they don't
seem to care about any of that the
presumption of innocence the only one
thing they care about is power and
winning that's it in control of your
life now we are 186 days away and you
are the ultimate jury the choice is
going to be clear you will decide the
fate of this great Republic and by the
way no hyperbole everything including
our way of life hanging in the balance